ma question s'adresse à madame la
Première ministre
la France se bloque depuis quelques
jours des millions de Français ne
peuvent plus circuler librement ne
peuvent plus travailler librement près
de 4000 stations sont aujourd'hui en
manque en défaut de carburant en
empêchant nos compatriotes de vivre et
de travailler pleinement
madame la Première ministre vous avez
commencé par nier la gravité de la
situation
non non il n'y a pas de pénurie répétée
il y a encore quelques jours monsieur
Véran rappelant ses déclarations
clairvoyantes et définitive sur
l'utilité des masques le président de la
République à lui a vu qu'une formule
tout aussi choquante refusée de
s'impliquer dans le conflit le faire
serait je le cite nous faire passer cul
par dessus tête on croit rêver on croit
rêver face à un tel mépris face à un tel
déni de la difficulté des millions de
Français
une nouvelle fois oui une nouvelle fois
rien est anticipé rien n'est géré et les
Français ressentent légitimement le
sentiment que la France n'est plus
gouvernée face au blocage nous vous
demandons solennellement que le
gouvernement fasse preuve de
responsabilité et d'autorité
certes il est plus facile de limoger des
policiers que de s'opposer à la CGT pour
autant pour autant madame la Première
ministre quand allez-vous en fin de
débloquer cette situation en procédant
aux réquisitions qui s'impose et que les
Français attendent